telling us about how to sim how
simulating balls and springs captures
the power of quantum Computing so
welcome Robin thanks Andy and thanks to
all the organizers for writing me uh
yeah thanks so much I've been to the
Simon since Year many times and I've
loved every little visit so please keep
inviting me
all right so I'm going to talk about uh
how simulating balls and springs
captures the power of quantum computing
and a more traditional title slide would
be this is the actual title of our paper
an exponential Quantum speed up and
simulating coupled classical oscillators
I'll explain what all that means and
this is Joint work with Ryan and Rolando
at Google Dominic Macquarie and Nathan
at University of Toronto and that's
where you can find it on the archives
okay so one slide summary of what this
talk is about we Define a new
computational problem and this new
computational problem is related to
simulating the time evolution of a
classical system of a bunch of balls
connected by Springs
and what we show is that this problem
can be solved by a quantum computer
efficiently so the problem is in dqp
and the upshot of this result is that
um well maybe we can find new
applications for quantum computers maybe
we can find classical systems in the
wild that people want to simulate and
then map it to our problem and then you
use our algorithm
um so that'll be the upshot of this
result on the other hand we also show
that the problem is bqp complete
um one interesting thing about this is
that it's a purely classical problem as
I'll describe to you
um but the other I try to bring
something BKP complete means you can
design new Quantum algorithms through
the classical system so you could
recover known Quantum algorithms by just
analyzing systems of balls and springs
in this case and I'll give you an
example of that as well at this time
all right so there's going to be an
outline of this talk so I'll first
explain what this problem is this the
one that I've been talking about that
has that is bqb complete and then to
discuss how you solve this problem I'm
going to do a review of Newtonian
mechanics
uh so I want to mention two things about
this first
this part might be really boring to the
physicists in the audience because like
you probably know this and this is
really basic so please feel free to zone
out or go on your phone look on Reddit
and secondly for the same physicists in
the audience if you catch me making
mistakes please point this out because
I'm not an expert in plutonium mechanics
so feel free to interrupt I mean we've
already had a lot of good discussion
with this conference but feel free to
say I mean yeah raise your hand or speak
up when if I make a mistake explain any
of the physics stuff in this talk
and once I describe the problem and once
I describe how you solve this problem
classically I'll tell you about Quantum
algorithm and I'll tell you I'll give
you some evidence of for why this
problem is hard
um that hopefully will be interesting
okay so let's start with the first part
uh what's this problem about
so this problem follows this General
class of problems that you've probably
seen a ton of if you took High School
physics which is you're given the
description of a system
and how it evolves in time and you're
told what the system looks like right
now and then you're asked to predict
what the system will look like after
time T so like in high school physically
from is like there's a ball and it's
moving with some speed and there's it's
acting under the force of gravity and
you've got to predict it's you know
where it's going to be its position and
velocity at time t or maybe there's an
inclined plane or whatever this is like
a classic phenophysics problem just the
time Evolution question
and so for example if we talk about
classical physics or like Newtonian
mechanics this this problem would look
like this I'll tell you the state of the
system right now at time t equal to zero
this will be the positions and
velocities of all the particles involved
and I'll tell you how the system evolves
with time and classically this would be
Newton's laws and for me to tell you
Newton's Laws which is like f equals m a
i need to tell you well both sides of
the equation which means I'll tell you
all the forces acting on all the
particles and I have to tell you the
mass of all the particles
okay
and to make this a computational problem
what would be your inputs and outputs
I'll give you these forces masses the
initial positions and velocities and
this time parameter T and you have to
Output the position and velocity at time
T So This Is How we'll make it a
computational problem
so this is just a general framework of
how these problems look like now let's
specialize to balls and springs the
advertised physical system that we're
going to talk about
okay so what's going on here so
there's going to be end balls
and
any pair of them can be connected by a
spring but like just for this example
I'm going to put them all on a line and
just connect the nearest Neighbors
and I'm also going to allow any of the
balls to be connected to a wall by a
spring so in this example I've just done
it on the two balls at the end of this
picture so here n equals eight and
right up 10 Springs
okay and so I want to analyze the
Dynamics of this system
so I want to know what happens
um
if if all these Springs start like this
and like all the they started these
positions and all the velocities are
zero maybe it just stays like this but
if I if I perturb one of them I want to
know like how this system evolves in
time
and you know as I said before what do we
need to know to understand the time
evolution of this classical system you
need to understand the masses of all of
these balls and you need to understand
the force acting on each ball
and for the force exerted by Spring
there's a there's a simple formula it's
called hooke's law and it says that the
force that a spring exerts on a ball is
minus Kappa times Delta X so Kappa is
the strength of the spring so Capital
zero that means there's no spring Kappa
being large means the string is really
strong
and Delta X is the amount by which the
spring is compressed or elongated
and there's a minus sign to show that
like if you compress the spring the
forces outwards so it's an opposite of
the direction
Delta X
Okay so
this is all I'm going to say about how
um like the physics of the system right
now so I'll come back to it later in my
Newton mechanics review and explain how
you actually solve this computational
problem but right now I just want to
give you this basic idea that once you
know this in principle you can solve you
can answer any question about this once
you know the force equation and you know
the masses that that's all you really
need to know
okay are there any questions at this
point
that's right you're also need ethical
damage yes
so your Springs will always be harmonic
so Focus law is when you say spring you
mean for the school right when I say
spring I mean something that follows the
situation
that's okay
any more impressions
but basically the masses and the
strengths of each string and of course
the initial position and velocity also
area control
but yeah let me let me formulate a
computational problem so
if this is all I told you like the most
natural computational problem you would
come up with is this one on this slide
which is there's uh four inputs the
first one is all the masses so I'm going
to call them M1 through MN
then there's spring constant so how many
of them are there I allow each pair of
balls to be connected by spring so
that's entrance to Spring constants and
then I allow each of the balls to also
be connected to a wall optionally and
any of these spring constants can be
zero so like you don't have to have
Springs everywhere but you know allowing
for this possibility so there's entry of
two plus n numbers cap and I'm going to
arrange them in a matrix so Kappa IJ is
the spring that connects ball light and
ball J and Kappa it is the same as
capitulated it's the same screen and I'm
going to say Kappa II is the value of
the spring console connecting the ball
to the wall
okay so that's a description of like the
essentially the Newton's law part the
mass and forces uh then the initial
position the velocities
this I'm going to denote as somewhere to
use x for my position that X1 to xn for
yeah masses and the argument is the time
so at Time Zero I wanted to know all the
positions and for velocity I'm going to
use this notation of putting a DOT to
represent time derivative this is by
Common and physics so x i dot means the
velocity will be nice particle again at
time zero so these are the initial
positions and velocities
uh
X as a numbers
right
yeah and say this earlier but yes
everything's one dimensional on this top
but this is this is
it's easier that way
um but it's not just it's it's yeah it's
not that it's more yeah and also it's
essentially without loss of generality
uh
I'll maybe talk about a little later on
like what will happen is if you want to
talk about like three-dimensional
systems we'll let you essentially three
coordinates for each
coordinate the original 3D object and
it'll work out but let me focus on the
1D case for now
you know like I mean it's one of the
only thing I'm using one position very
well like it's just it has to satisfy
those equations like
um
uh yeah maybe you can actually build it
in one Dimensions it's just I'm using
one real coordinate for um every
particle
so this I mean I'll talk about this
later but like this system operations
doesn't just capture balls in Spring but
it captures like a whole wide variety of
phenomenon physics where like these
things may not actually evolves or
Springs they might be
yeah other things and these equations
could come up so everything's coupled
with it but yeah if you're just thinking
of a simple system of all it's a bit
unnatural to have spring is going
through other walls right but the
equations will make sense
[Laughter]
might zone out of the physics part of
the stock anyway they'll be like you
know
but I'll tell you the equations of
motion which is probably what the
physics people care about once you see
those you'll be like oh this is just
classic coupled harmonic oscillators I
don't need to care about all of your
stories so far so most of the story is
just for the computer centers who don't
know or saw this so many years ago and
forgot this is high schools
connected to because it depends on like
effects which direction
uh right that's a good question
um
the um
yeah um
when I show you the equation emotional
make more sense yeah what the world
terms it just corresponds to a term and
the equation of motion which is like
minus Kappa i i x i yeah
that's right except uh all of my
position coordinates are with respect to
the rest positions so it's not like the
walls at all so yeah
um it doesn't really matter right now
it'll make it means it'll matter once I
set up the equation the motion but what
I'll want to do is I'll have to l12 has
each of the X scores it's relative to
where they start from so in this
position for example I'll want all of
the exponents to be zero like all the
velocities are zero at this point I'll
also have all the x coordinates zero and
this this will correspond to the vector
of position velocities being the old
zero sector
and so like the walls of the with
respect to this
yeah
suggestion Robin's next time just make
it um induction capacitor circuits and
you'll get rid of a lot of these
comments
that's right or uh yeah yeah or maybe
have one slide for physicist so I just
give you the equations of motion and I
was like that's that's that makes sense
but uh anyway for now let's just think
about I can move through balls Springs
that's okay
um
okay so this would be one way if you
would try to formalize a computational
problem I give you all of this the
equations of motion I tell you the
initial positions velocities I tell you
time T and you have to Output the final
positions in
as it is
well that's a totally reasonable way of
formalizing this problem
except this problem is I mean you can't
have a Quantum speed up for this problem
because well you know
so what's going on firstly you can solve
this problem classically in time
polynomial and the number of masses
and the output size is also n so like
any algorithm whether classical or
Quantum would have to write down an
output of size and there's not really
going to be an exponential speed over so
I want an exponential speed up so this
is not the version of the problem that
I'm going to be talking about but this
would be just the the most obvious way
to write down a computational problem
so what I want to do is come up with a a
different
like a version of this problem which is
still essentially talking about the same
system but I want to encode the inputs
succinctly
and that's going to open up the
possibility of an exponential speed up
so how do I do that I want to specify
all of these these four inputs so simply
and also on the output to be small
because right now it's an output of size
n that's that's no good because if you
have an upper size then you need it in
time to write it down
so I'm going to change the way I
represent all of these things so so
let's start talking about
how I'm going to do this
okay so as I said we want succinct
inputs and what I mean is
if capital N is 2 to the little N I want
inputs that are size polynomial and
little n or in terms of the original
capital and it's polylog capital n
okay so how do we deal with the masses
so if you remember from the previous
slide there's n masses right and I want
to describe N Things to you but I want
to only use like poly login an input of
polylogan size so one thing you can do
is you can just assume that you're given
a circuit that describes the masses to
you so I'll give you I'll give you a
polynomial size circuit that accepts as
input the name of a mass the label of a
mass this is a number between one and
capital N it does some polynomial time
computation and spits out the mass am I
so what this means is of course that
a polynomial size circuit cannot encode
arbitrary lists of n numbers so this is
saying that the masses have a lot of
structure but there's some formula that
tells you what Mi is from I so for
example the ith Mass could be I squared
that would be unacceptable
um example where you would have a
polymer size circuit or all the masses
are the same they're all mass one so
things like this so we're going to
restrict our Focus to special cases of
this problem where I can actually encode
the input succinctly
and the choice I'm going to make here is
that the masses are represented by a
polynomial size circuit which takes us
into the label and upwards am I
okay does this make sense to everyone
because I'm going to do more of this
kind of trick okay
okay so those masses that was a vector
of length
um n the second thing is this set of
spring constants so this is like a this
is a matrix this is an N by n Matrix
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
assume two things firstly this Matrix
I'm going to assume is sparse and what
that means is although it could have up
to you know two to the N entries in any
lower column and we're going to assume
that only has polynomials in many
entries
and the second thing is again same as
this I'm going to assume there's a
circuit that describes this for me
so formulating this Matrix this Kappa
Matrix it stars as poly and non-zero
entries and again I can take there's
some circuit which takes us input I and
outputs all of the non-zero entries in
in row I so there's only polynomially
many of them so that's not a problem
I'm now going to assume that this
coupling is is far so every Mass can
only be covered a polynomial in many
other masses
and again this is represented by
polynomial size circuit that takes in
the name of a mass that tells you all
the masses it's connected to and all the
spring constants
the strings
in terms of matters and this is a list
of followers
about it
okay
so these are two of the four inputs then
I've shown you how to encode uh what
we're going to assume about their
succinct encodings
the third thing was the list of initial
positions and velocities
and so here what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to assume these vectors are
sparse so that means although they're
vectors of size 2 to the N I'm just
going to assume there's only Pauline and
non-zero entries and you just tell me
what all these entries are and the
others are zero so again that's a
polynomial sized input
that's good the fourth thing was time
that's just it's just a number so it's
not a big deal but I didn't say this
earlier but all of the numbers appearing
so far I'm also going to require them to
be polynomial sized so I'm going to
recap all these requirements but I'm
just telling you now that this is also
another
constraint I'm going to put on the
problem
so you can't have ex like a spring
constant that's of size 2 to the end or
a mass that's such like I'm not going to
allow that either
so this completes the input so what's
left is the output right so the output
was again the position and velocity of
every particle or every ball at time t
so we can't do the same trick that we
did for the inputs there yeah
for uh three
um now yeah efficiently computable is
not okay
um there's something a little more
General than sparse that's going to be
okay and it's going to relate to what
kind of quantum states can you prepare a
column at a time as far States as one
example so that's what I'm going to use
that example throat but more generally
it'll be later like yeah what
certainly just being able to compute
entries
description of data itself
on the next slide
thank you
so you don't have to load them in memory
I'll show you everything again but I'm
just walking through each of the
in-person hours one by one telling you
how I'm going to make them make them
succinct
any more questions
sorry for the next level you've
basically encoded the local Quantum
handles
it's great
you have to invoke balls and Springs at
all because
Albert states of local hamiltonian is
also a sparse Matrix that's two n by two
ends
I mean this is very analogous to like
the class of Hamilton is that we usually
focus on right so we talk about like
simulating like Quantum systems on a
quantum computer but we don't actually
mean we can simulate any old hamiltonian
we usually restrict our Focus
specifically the sparse hamiltonians
which is exactly of this this model so
I'm saying we're doing the same thing
but instead of for hamiltonians for this
Vector of for this Matrix of spring
constants
but the Dynamics are different right
it's not it's not Hamilton Dynamics it's
like
the way you solve the string problem is
by diagonalizing the same Nation
to talk about poison Springs but it's
really just diagonalized
Matrix that's true classic like in order
to solve hamiltonian simulation board as
well as a string problem you wouldn't
bet Analyze This exponentially large
Matrix but the equations of motions are
different so it's not it's not it's not
like I'm literally solving the same
problem
I will end up with a differential
equation that's right but it will at
least not obviously be
the Schrodinger equation but
uh
that's right
eventually this is why
that's the reason why this the system
will like capture the power of one of
the paintings I face it because it will
be complete because you are able to both
simulated by mapping it to a Quantum
hamiltonian and vice versa Quantum
Hamilton back to a system of all these
breaks
so yeah you guys are
already seeing where this is going but
any any questions about how we're
encoding stuff just so everybody's on
the same page and especially those of
you are seeing this for the first time
like how we encode exponentially large
objects with polynomial size inputs
all right so okay
and so I haven't finished because I've
only told you how the inputs are encoded
the output from the previous slide was
also some exponentially large Vector
right you have to tell me all the
positions and velocities
and unlike what we did for the input
Vector where we said well let's just
assume it's sparse you can't just assume
this output is parse because the output
is not in your control but it's just
some vector
and there are several things you can do
there you do here for the output I'm
just going to say I'm just going to ask
for something simple I'm only going to
ask for the velocity of the first ball
as the output so that's going to be my
new output instead of telling me all of
the all of the positions and velocities
I'm just going to say tell me the
velocity of the first ball up to this
additive error inverse polynomial
so let me put all of this together and
give you like a formal problem
definition
so I'm calling it a simplified decision
problem because well it's a decision
problem like you just output yes or no
the way I formulated here and it's
simplified Because the actual problem we
solve is more General but it's okay for
you to focus on this for for the rest of
the talk this problem will be keeping
complete and it'll have all the
properties I talked about and
yeah this will be we can design new
Quantum algorithms using this version of
the problem and so on so we don't
necessarily need to talk about this
General problem but I will get to it
later on but if you've seen this for the
first time it's a little overwhelming to
see the general version of this problem
so that's why I just want to focus on
balls and Springs
so this is a summary of the stuff I
talked about in the last two slides or
so
[Music]
yeah so I'm going to measure everyone's
position relative to the rest position
oh so so for example in this in this
line case like x equal to zero for all
of them would correspond to them being
so yeah
question what you're doing here is
really to generate uh random pH like
permission sparse Matrix and talk about
the second order uh differential
equation associated with this formation
Matrix
all right
uh right that is also yeah so the maybe
a more basic question is is that clear
the first order equation uh
corresponding to the same permission
Matrix is P2P which is uh you consider
the shoulder version of it yeah
it's a well-known result
oh I think uh whether is time
independent hamiltonian simulation with
this particular
um so you mean like this Matrix differs
from an arbitrary Hamilton because like
personally all the numbers are real but
in fact they're all positive
um
yeah uh so this is a classical second
order new the Kenyan Dynamics so you can
actually write it down a like time you
can download
into the position and velocity as the
face space just at the University you
can lie down
the difficulty here is because the
Matrix size is very large I see right
and so the way to argue about BP is you
start from this Matrix you consider this
second order differential equation and
uh yeah
great but I'm asking whether there is a
to this community
whether the more basic question has been
answered that is the high partiality of
PSI equal to this Matrix times the PSI
is B
right so I guess maybe what you're
asking is yes is hamiltonian circulation
time independent Hamilton
uh so this version that all positive
numbers
that are Universal basically uses a
positive
okay okay
so then if that is already known because
I didn't know whether it was now what's
the really the new thing compared to
that so um
yeah maybe most people here don't know
what I'm talking about oh it's
definitely don't know what you're
talking about when you talk about a
second order
discover the hamiltonian so uh yeah let
me talk about those
okay this okay so this is our problem
um
one more questions
what's the main result the tomatoes out
is that this problem is in bqp
um and in fact there's also a more
General problem I'll talk about later
that's also in bqp
but so you know I took this problem that
was that at the at its outset was pretty
interesting it was about simulating a
system of balls and springs and whatever
but then I introduced a whole ton of
constraints right so you might be
worried that now I made the problem too
simple right right so like is it from
too easy now like is it that I put so
many constraints on the problem
that this problem is now easy to solve
classically so it's that's not clear
right now because
yeah all I'm saying is that this problem
is solvable on a quantum computer so the
second dimension is that the problem is
also vqp hard and hence pqb complete and
in fact in the mainspeak you'd be hard
even if we make further special
um yeah assumptions like we can take all
the masses to be one all the spring
consonants are bounded between like zero
and four whatever and it's the sparseity
is a constant and in fact the initial
state is very simple as well all the
positions are zero so they started the
rest positions and all the velocities
are essentially zero except like two of
the masses have some velocity so even in
this very special situation the problem
remains bqp hard
and another evidence that we get for the
problem being hard is that if we think
of this problem in the world of query
complexity so
which is where
um you know some black box that knows
the spring constructs so same setup as
now like there's this Matrix of spring
constants it's sparse but it's not
written down anywhere you're not given
the circuit but you're giving Black Box
access to it another question is how
many queries you have to make this black
box to solve this problem so what we can
show is that any classical algorithm or
deterministic or randomized would need
two to the Omega n queries to solve this
problem whereas our algorithm solves it
in polynomial in many queries so if you
want you can view this as a query
complexity separation
and I'll tell you more about this result
because it's kind of nice the way we
prove this is we show how you can solve
the glute trees problem which is a
famous query complexity problem with an
exponential separation between classical
and Quantum algorithms we'll show how to
solve this glute trees Problem by
mapping it to a system of balls and
springs in kind of the obvious way
so that's uh that's a statement of my
results
there's no questions about this maybe
I'll I'll come back a little bit to this
question of why are we focused on balls
and springs and it's also
um
yeah this was related Toby's suggestion
that like maybe I should talk about like
electrical circuits with capacitors
inductors and that would be an easier
explanation for physicists
yeah I don't know how familiar computer
scientists are with capacitors inductors
I don't know if that's an easier model
to start with but um yeah think about it
but uh the point is that the same
equations of motion that you write down
for these balls of Springs essentially
the same ones also appear when you do a
whole bunch of other things like
electrical circuits and motion coupled
pendulums
um analyzing vibrations and molecules so
it comes up all over the place
and yeah
Springs and it's essentially a formal
system and I mean yes it can be very
very large but the dispersion relation
is smooth
so there's a lot of redundant in degrees
of freedom but it's not like you have an
exponentially large number of things
right I mean in that case if you
specifically know that it's not so you
really need I think to really show that
it is very very hard you need to make
all this coupling to be kind of really
weird
to right it is not like a naturally
mapped to any of those kind of physical
setups
right using the hardness of the probably
a large number of degrees of freedom and
using the hardness of the problem well
not
it relies on the fact that we can tune
all this massive and string constructs
like if they're all the same or
something that it wouldn't that's true I
mean I need something
or something very straightforward like
some very easy functional let's try I
need some I need some degrees of freedom
and input to have a computational
problem right like to prove esthetic
statements about complexity like if if
everything was straight like yeah if all
of them were known a known relationship
for all the messes and stuff like
like yeah where would I encode that the
difficulty of the computational problem
right so this is the choice we make but
it's in it's actually hiding in the
spring constants because I said like in
all of the hardness examples the masses
can all be one too so it's really the
fact that all the spring constants are
tunable where all the difficulties lying
you can even assume the message
um you know you said you could
um
each spring constant will like leave it
into like some gay amplitude
yeah it'll be pretty bad would you think
perfectly because some regular platform
so for example if you you know
um
is a big regular
that would have been even easier
so certainly the BKP Hardware you know a
lot of funeral parameters to embed
arbitrary circuits
so once that's gone
foreign
but the pattern will correspond to the
the gates in the quantum circuit which
we did the reduction from so
thank you
I think I'm not sure
I have to step to the reduction we see
exactly what happens if you start from a
nice Quantum circuit whatever that means
like maybe some kind of regular pattern
games it doesn't snap
share the same size and then it's the
Dynamics itself that gives you the
preview accomplishment
based on me
yes sir
for many of you
let me get to the point right explain
what equations being sold and how it
gets mapped for hamiltonian simulation
then you'll see what kind of hamiltonian
comes about
that's one more question about this or
physical mapping yeah
geometrically local Quantum circuit do
we end up with
geometric locality or any kind of
structure and
the springs
maybe but not uh
no I think what will happen geometric
locality
um great Quantum circuit will get
translated to something like you only
connect things that are you only connect
masses I mean balls whose labels are
close by and Hamming distance
into any local space so
yeah of course more is something weird
if you give me login Dimensions or
something or whatever to embed the
Hamming Cube into space then maybe it'll
be local
I was going to try and let you carry on
but since there were comments about this
in Hamilton when we're trying to
construct cure me hard hamiltonians what
we learned is if we want something
uniform kind of in space or translation
variant or the best thing to do is to
reduce from Turing machines rather than
from gate circuit model
if you want something uniform here you
might find that you get sort of
uniformity in spatial translation
variants for free kind of doing a
reduction from that and I bet your
techniques just go through for that
um okay so for yeah so for those of your
business you probably know why I'm
focusing on the system because capitals
come up everywhere but just for people
who have seen this for the first time
it's not just that we specifically care
about balls and Sprints but the same
equations emotions come up everywhere
and there's a deeper fundamental region
it's not what kind of a coincidence it's
like oh look there's like 17 different
systems described by the same couple
harmonic oscillator equations but it
turns out because of
um this thing if you analyze a physical
system a stable equilibrium under a
certain kind of physical system which
has a name which is uh
the physical systems that have where the
force is called a conservative Force so
that means the force arises from the
potential to the forces of gradient of
potential energy so if you have a system
like this and it's in stable equilibrium
so it means everything at rest and
velocity zero will just tend to stay
there so if you like hook something it
wants to come back which kind of reminds
you of a spring like if you poke some
Focus spring or spring it tries to come
back so it's a general phenomenon that
you have a system in table equilibrium
when you poke it a little bit or you pop
everything in the system a little bit it
tries if it's stable this means it tries
to come back and that means if you write
down the equations of motion to some
approximation
that's why I'm saying per term so
perturbating equations of motion you
will basically get the same equation so
this is why these equations come up over
and over again and pick out coupled
harmonic oscillators
it's not a coincidence there's a deeper
reason and this is why it's interesting
but anyway if you if you don't care
about the motivation it doesn't matter
you can just focus on the system of
walls
right so let me uh okay so let's let's
do a quick like Newtonian mechanics
reviewer like how do you set this
problem up as a formal computational
problem like what are these differential
equations there are several questions
alluded to
all right so let's start with let's just
start with one ball and one spring so
it's gonna be the easiest case to handle
liver and more stable that has extra
conditions that is the Matrix in January
so the way I set it up with balls and
strengths that the when I write down the
differential equation that Matrix will
be PSD just by Construction
I mean that's the motivation but the
actual setup is to we have a polynomial
size a circuit
that give you i that spells out J and
Kappa i j is that obvious how to
construct illustration my system all I
need is the string constant should be
positive like I don't need to enforce
anything else the The Matrix that
appears in the differential equation is
not the same as the same constant Matrix
something like a it's like a graph
reflection like it will be possible
separation
right so that's not something else
so the yeah the problem as stated was
the formal problem there's no extra
stuff to be stated
good so okay let's do a quick review of
Newtonian Mechanics for those of you
haven't seen this and let's start with
one ball one spring
so this is what it looks like the first
thing you might observe is that my balls
are now changed to squares and blocks
but you know it's all the same because
they're pointing those are pointing
masses so it doesn't matter
so okay so there's one Mass I'm going to
call it m there's one spring I'm going
to go color Kappa and this is the
situation in which like you can just
leave it be in the system won't do
anything so this is its rest position
and I'm going to call that x equal to
zero so so for all the masses I'm going
to talk about the position Corner
relative to the rest position
and this is what it looks like when you
project this okay
cool and as I said how do you solve this
system you need to know this Newton's
law and hooks a lot of the building how
springs work and you get this kind of
different liquid so what's going on here
the left hand side is mass times
acceleration acceleration is the second
derivative position
and the right hand side is this minus
Kappa X so that's over here
so this is a differential equation so
you can solve it and you'll get uh well
you won't get a unique solution you'll
get many solutions so you need to know
the initial conditions to fix down the
solution and once I know uh the position
of velocity at times zero then you can
determine XT
and in fact uh let's yeah let's go
through this it's going to be pretty
straightforward and the way you do this
is you take the previous equation which
is MX double dot equals minus Kappa X
and you do this variable substitution
like Omega square root of Kappa over M
which is well defined because
these are positive numbers and then you
get the simple equation which is X
double dot equals minus Omega squared x
you can see it has two solutions sine
and cosine you can plug them in and see
that both of them work
and so there's two solutions and we had
two initial conditions and you can you
know plug them in and you'll get some
solution like this so X of T is this
this expression over here and x dot to
use this inspiration over here
so this is like a full solution to the
system of one ball and one string
and
um so I've written this just so you know
that there is a way to do this but also
I want to highlight something about the
solution which is that if we
um
if we plug the position velocity on the
X and Y axis
and we plot the location of this
particle as a dot in this diagram you'll
see that this dot moves and it moves not
on a circle but this is an elliptical
path
which is which is a little Annoying we
would like this to be in a circle so one
thing we can do is you can rescale the X
and Y coordinates and then it'll look
like a circle and one way to rescale
them is you multiply the square root of
the mass over here you multiply by
square root of the
spring constant over here and the
equation of a circle is that in this
coordinate square plus that coordinate
square equals a constant and I'm going
to call that constant e
uh rather suggestively so for those who
are not physicists do you recognize this
equation
so this is the conservation of
mechanical energy so this is the kinetic
energy this is the potential energy and
they sum to some constant e and this
constant Remains the Same even though
the left-hand side of these equations
our functions are prime they're inside
this fixed so the energy is conserved as
the system evolves in time
okay I mentioned this because this is
going to be relevant to the solution
okay so this is a full solution to how
how you work with one ball and one
spring you have n balls and end Springs
it's kind of the same thing it's just
the equations look a little more
complicated
and this is a set of this is the second
order differential equations that people
were earlier asking questions about so
this is what happens you have these n
variables x one through x n and you have
n equations one for each ball and so the
left hand side is the mass times the
acceleration of that ball the right-hand
side is the sum of all the forces acting
on it and so these are all the forces
acting are because of
what it's coupling to other balls the
you know the date
and uh this is the force acting on it
because of the spring I was talking
about that's connected to a wall
and so you get this system of equations
it's a it looks a little messy but what
you can do is there's n equations and
you can write all this into a matrix
form
and what you'll get is
something that looks nice like this now
where X Vector is just a vector with all
the x coordinates uh this is the you
know second derivative
m is a diagonal matrix which is all the
masses just M1 through MN and F is some
Matrix that just you collect all these
terms and you'll get this Matrix f
so you can write it nicely like this so
this is a second order differential
equation in terms of these variables
that are vectors of length n
and finally again if you remember the
in the system with one ball and one
spring we did this variable substitution
to make the equation look a little
prettier and I'm going to do the same
kind of variable substitution here I'm
going to find some variable y that is
the square root of n times x and then
I'm going to take this guy and just
change some variables
and that makes the equation look even
nicer just y double dot equals minus a y
bar and the important thing is a is
positive semi-definite and the reason
I'm mentioning this is this looks
exactly like the one variable solution
we had earlier which was like X double
dot is minus Omega squared x and this
minus Omega square is similar to minus a
because a is a PSD Matrix so all of its
eigenvalues are positive so you you
really can think of it as a square of
some some number
so yeah so this is the final this is the
equation we finally care about so if you
don't care about all this derivation
like this is the second order
differential equation that we're going
to try to solve on a quantum computer
and it comes about in this way but if
you just want to take one thing home
this is the thing we're going to use in
the next few slides
okay so now there's enough setup that I
can describe the quantum algorithm to
but before I move on to that any
questions about this part
okay okay maybe maybe everybody knew how
balls in Springfield except me but
that's fine that's a hopefully this
review helps someone
um okay so what are we going to do so as
I alluded before
we already know that simulating the time
evolution of a Quantum system isn't bqp
in fact it's a famously bqp complete
problem
and I want to map this problem to the
time evolution of a Quantum system
and okay I just want to remind you of
like the numbers that are involve here
so I want to think of a Quantum system
on log n Bits which is like so
originally if I had capital N masses in
my ball and swing system I have login
qubits sorry
the vector space is a size n right so if
I'm talking about login qubits but the
but as we know for time evolution of
quantum systems if the hamiltonian
is sparse the Hamilton governing
Dynamics we can actually solve this
problem efficiently on a quantum
computer which is time poly login n is
the size of these vectors and this is
how the mapping is going to go I'm going
to take capital N my original system
which are capitaland balls and map it to
a Quantum system but the quantum system
is only going to have log n qubits so
that's where the the exponential savings
is going to come about that's where the
exponential speed up is going to come
about
okay so that's the big picture game plan
and more precisely what's happening is
I'm going to take our problem which is
time evolution of n balls and springs
map it to the time emotional Quantum
system but the quantum system size is
exponentially smaller it's only using
log n qubits and when I say map I mean
like two different things one is that
I'm going to map the state of the
classical system to a state of the
quantum system what that means is like a
state of a classical positions and
velocities the state of a Quantum system
is you know the Quantum State the one
that we all know and love that's going
to be on login qubits
and note that this makes sense like I
can I can encode capital N numbers in
log n qubits so
and then I'm going to map these like
like how the system evolves so there's
just Newton's equations like this
equations out on the previous Slide the
second order differential equation
whatever to the analogous thing for how
a Quantum system evolves which is a
hamiltonian
and once I didn't explain both of these
maps and these maps are consistent then
then the algorithm will will work and so
if you want to see this as a picture
what I just mean is that I have a
classical State at Time Zero I can map
it to a Quantum state of Time Zero
classical set of time T I can map it to
a Quantum status I'm T and if I evolve
this with Newton's equations and evolve
this with hamiltonian simulation these
two past two weeks
okay so let me tell you two ways of
doing this the first one is simpler but
it has a bunch of downsides but it'll be
simple to understand
at least
the intuition will be clear of why you
can map that that equation to uh
so this is the first solution so what
was the equation we're trying to solve
so we call this was this y double dot
equals minus a y Vector where y the Y
Vector is later the X Vector with some
masses and a was some PSD Matrix that
came about from the spring constants
so this is the equation I want to solve
but I want to map this to the
Schrodinger equation
what governs time dynamics of the
quantum system so what does the
schroding integration look like it looks
like this it looks like the derivative
of the state vector
is minus I times some hamiltonian times
the state vector and the simultaneous
has to be a hermitian matrix that's the
constraint on it
so I want to massage this equation to
make it look like this equation that's
that's the goal that's what I mean by
mapping the classical system to a
Quantum system
and there's actually okay there's one
way to see this that's kind of a trick
it may not make that much sense but I'm
just going to add the same term to both
sides of this equation the term I'm
going to add is I square root a y
just let's just add this to both sides
of the equation
and what you'll see is the right hand
side
um maybe let's see the left hand side so
the left hand side should have two terms
which is the second derivative of y and
I square root a y first derivative and
this guy over here after this D by DT
adds a DOT on both of them is exactly
this term plus this term
and the right hand side is also correct
algebra
um the I square root a y dot is the
first term here and the second term is
coming from
this guy because I took square root a
out common and I squared a are coming
so and why did I do this because now it
looks like d by D of something is I
times the hamiltonian times the same
thing which looks exactly like this
equation over here so this is just like
syntactic manipulation of
this second order differential version
to make it look like a schroding
equation but you can actually carry this
through and this gives you a Quantum
algorithm it's just not very it's not as
good as the one I'm going to talk about
later but but I thought I'll show this
it kind of gives you some idea for why
it's even possible to do this
maybe gives people some intuition yeah
uh sorry normalization of what
ah yes that's a good question so you're
saying like this guy
but this is uh so yeah so this is
actually permission so that's because
um this guy here was PSD so the square
root is that's fine so this will
actually be a normally preserving map
because if you start over the permission
in this Hamilton's equipment this I'm
going in the starting years according
the time Evolution will be this unitary
e to the ihp and that's the unitary and
so this guy's normal actually we
conserved it's not clear to see why
uh that's right yeah when you define a
Quantum State yeah you can Define
yeah to find the quantity that's the
normalized version of this and it's
normal actually
so that's not that's not
good yeah this this way of looking at it
is like not very intuitive to me so I'll
present a second way that makes much
more sense but
as well
yeah
but why don't you just
take the second derivative of the
trailer
and
whoever is here but I wonder okay but
here's like the second door being
deleted the original thing
okay or maybe yeah
okay so let me tell you the better
solution which is the one we use that
gives you more efficient algorithms
um
which is uh specific what are we trying
to do are we trying to match the
classical State at a given time to a
Quantum state
so we're trying to have these two n
numbers these positions and velocities
to a Quantum state
so yeah as Mars pointed out like Quantum
Stakes have Norm one right so we need
some mapping that takes these numbers
Maps it to a vector whose Norm is one
and in fact we want the mapping to be
such that the norm remains normal
throughout the computation right because
the quantum Prime evolution is going to
preserve the norm of the state
so I want some quantity that's related
to these parameters that is actually
conserved
throughout the time Evolution and we
talked about this earlier this is like
one example of such a quantity that's
conserved throughout time evolution is
the total energy so which is like this
would be the conservation of energy
equation for n balls and end Springs
which is like this is all the kinetic
energies this is all the potential
energies for the pairwise Springs this
is all the potential energies for the
strings with the balls and walls
so this is a conserved party so once I
have some equation like this which is
like a bunch of things left hand side
these are all time dependent things but
they are conservative time I can define
a Quantum state whose entries are
essentially these guys
and the quantum States normal remain the
same or it'll remain e but you know
divided by one over square root e or
something outside so that the normal
domain one throughout the computation
and so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to take a Quantum State who is so
there's entries of of three types
there'll be a bunch of entries that look
like square root of a mass times a
velocity they'll be entries like this
and like I'll tell you how many of each
type there are less like n masses it's
like n choose two of these pairwise
Springs and then there's n of these
Springs to walls components
this guy just turns out to be the vector
Y Bar I defined earlier because when I
was in this variable transformation I
transformed the X variables to Y
variables from multiplying by square
root to the masses for some mathematical
convenience but it turns out to be nice
this is just a y vector
uh y dot Vector sorry and this is some
linear combination of the Y's because
it's a it's a linear combination of the
X's but X is related to y's through so
many conversions so it's again some
linear combination of y's so if I show
you the whole Vector it's going to look
a little ugly but this is what the
vector is going to be
here
I mean the knife
should
identification my question is indeed is
it clear that order N squared because
the normalization or could there be an
order hello can you do it fewer right so
even if you just put the first equation
you can do with this
right right
that's what you always do that's right
and then it's the first one of the flash
equation but of course it's not
non-preserved it's all good
um
the previous solution that I gave
actually uses exactly a vector of length
which is a
this guy is actually a maker of length n
and I'm using the imaginary part to put
in like
the position stuff and the real parts
are in there
um velocity part so this is really the
most succinct way of doing it I mean you
certainly can't develop this and okay
that's probably basically
eight minutes right away so basically
you take a little second order equation
like into a complex version right that's
what we're thinking of the solution
right
the real and complex imaginary parts to
distort both like
you could expect stuff from that it's
not sort of expect here how do you
extract stuff from it this is why this
is why the solution is not that great
because now I'm combining the real
imaginary parts and like it's going to
be harder to expect that quantities I
care about in the second solution like
all the quantities I care about like
kinetic and protection I just appeared
like by themselves it's going to be nice
for computational
you would have access to everything
immediately and you would still not
skate pathetically now right
that's right I don't know
the definition of course
and you'd want that to be normal
preserving yeah exactly exactly that's
why I'm asking if there's always um I
yeah I don't know
arguments
yeah I don't know yeah yeah
any other questions about this this
place
anything else so far
oh yeah something over this this the
state that we're going to talk about
the
the important thing about the state is
it's Norm is one and the normal one
equation is exactly the conservation of
energy statement so I'm storing
essentially what I'm storing is I'm
storing the kinetic energy of the first
ball in the first component of a square
root of kinetic energy that's what's
important this kinetic is the second guy
and the second component and so on and
then here I'm showing the potential
energy that's stored in the spring that
connects the ball Wonder Ball to it so
each each component of my Vector has an
interpretation it's throwing some kind
of energy either kinetic or potential
so that's the string that connects the
first ball to the wall
so this is showing the energy stored in
that spring and so on
the last three
and this is this is like a super
explicit way of writing it down this is
like the more compact we've already done
it's this y Vector which was same as the
X Factor of the Sun
multiplied by this Mass
and the second part of the vector is
against some linear transformation on
these position coordinates
whatever represent by B
Matrix square root
yes
oh in the previous solution
here yeah yeah yeah so this is part of
the this solution has downsides because
you only have Oracle access to a in the
Assumption or whatever you're going to
circle so you can do Hamilton estimation
on the square root of handle time the
joke access to but like this will
require
yeah essentially face estimation so
you're going to have pretty bad
dependence on the error you have to
resolve stuff it's not the most
efficient way to do it but but you can
do it we give this Solution on our paper
as well let me work it out we tell you
exactly what the overall complexity is
going to be it's going to be much worse
than the second solution but
it works
oh no no this is kind of just an
inspiration or like this is one way to
solve the problem it's totally valid way
to solve a problem it's just not the
best way to solve it like the second
solution will be better
so I presented just so that it's clear
at least in principle you can solve it
because this is how you can in principle
map this equation
but I'm going to use a different mapping
in my second solution which is to have
these states that look like this
which are normalized because of the
conservation of energy in the previous
case I was not clear why that state was
normal and even it was just like some
some real part was complex part I added
them they turned it Remains the norm
remains conserved but that was not
totally obvious it's clear to see
because it's just like is this
um yeah this is a total energy that it
means
answered throughout the computation
and yeah once you have chosen this
representation for our system like I'm
gonna map a classical state to this
Vector it's going to be much easier to
see what the Dynamics looks like
so Y and X are basically the same thing
so if the masses are all one then they
are literally the same thing so you can
just think of X and Y as the same
variable so these are the dot variables
the first end and these are like linear
combinations of non-dotted variables so
that's why sums linear transformation
yeah so yeah yeah if you want to think
of an X analyze the same thing
and right so now I have to show you what
is the hamiltonian so as I said before
this is the state we're going to talk
word y dot b dagger y
it's Norm is one independent of time
that's good that's a good start
the second fact which is true but I want
to prove it here is that in fact BB
dagger is a this is the a from uh you
know we're trying to solve y double dot
equals minus A1
and this happens because essentially it
is a graphical portion and B is a
sensitive
I think that it's true you can verified
by computation
and
that's really nice because yes as I'm
saying a is this this is the equation
we're trying to solve like the second
derivative of y is minus a times y
itself and what you can do is you can
just write down this equation and see
that any solution y actually satisfies
this so so this is a matrix equation we
can write down the two separate
equations that's talking about
the first equation will give you uh
essentially y double dot s minus a y
second equation is kind of trivial and
this has again the format that we like
which is the Schrodinger equation format
it's saying that the time derivative is
on Vector now it's normalized it's Norm
one which is cool is minus I times some
hamiltonian times the same Vector again
so this is
this is the short integration and we can
solve this with hamiltonian simulation
you can create the starting state so if
you can create the state corresponding
to size 0 on your quantum computer in
polynomial time then you can create PSI
T by just appealing to known results on
hamiltonian simulation
and recover what I said earlier like the
constraint I put was that you only have
polynomial many non-zero entries and
yeah it's a known fact that you can
create Quantum states with problem in
many observe entries one computer so so
it's okay so we can create the initial
State we can do hamiltonian simulation
you have to check some conditions for
hamiltonian simulation to be true like
the Matrix has to be sparse and it has
to like bounded entries and so on but
it'll work out with the assumptions that
I gave
and so you'll create the state just call
a off-the-shelf black box hamiltonian
simulation algorithm
and get this date rather you'll get the
final state which is
the same thing but you know at time t
and once you have the state you can do
many things with it one thing you can do
is you can sample from the corresponding
probability distribution this might tell
you something interesting so it's
sampling from this distribution where
like let's say you fix the total energy
to be one so it's sampling either a ball
or a spring proportional to the amount
of energy that's stored in it so that
might be a useful task but another thing
you can do is you can estimate some
quantities of your care about like for
example you can estimate the first entry
to inverse polynomial error like the
first entry you know along with the
normalization between respond there this
is just like if I give you a probability
distribution and I tell you to estimate
the first entry to you know added a
better Epsilon you need like one over
Epsilon squared copies of the
probability distribution so same
phenomenon so I can get you the kinetic
energy of the first ball divided by E so
the fraction of the total energy that's
stored in the first ball to some inverse
polymer or or the potential energy in
some spraying or the kinetic energy of
some subset of balls
is the total energy it's like this
normalization constant here
so
did it
that's right but when you started you
only had polynomial of many of them
moving so e is number
and you can actually compute a quick
workout because the initial position and
velocity Vector was very small so
there's only polynomial manipulations
velocity so you can just like go through
them compute e is going to be some
number between
the energy stored in a typical ball
might be extremely small that's right
that's why I can only give you additive
poly estimates so like typically the
energy might be much smaller probably
than any then you have nothing
what is your decision
uh it was a decision problem that I did
a while ago which is just whether the
first entry here is bigger or smaller
than so I'll give you two numbers A and
B and the inverse normally separated and
you can tell me if this first number is
less than a or bigger than b if I can
solve the classical Dynamics
is the first ball and does it have
kinetic energy more than something or
less than something I must ask you to
follow
are you what are you relying on in terms
of this generic results
simulate this laplacian classically that
it will solve your Quantum thing but I
agree that your mapping is working in
One Direction but I'm not seeing how
you know the classical algorithm will
take exponentially longer because you
write down this environment Matrix
you'll diagonalize it with any algebra
and so on so it'll take uh yes it'll be
like it'll be an exponential Dynamic
compared to this being a polynomial
phenomena that's the difference
any any other questions
in this way I think yeah
and what's the advantages
so in the simple one um firstly you
don't have access to these quantities
directly so we had
in a simple solution
there's the the real and imaginary part
for a couple which is which is not a big
deal but the thing is that we don't have
these terms that correspond to a
separate spring constant so one thing
maybe the more computationally annoying
thing is you need to square root a
hamiltonian but you just don't have
access to you only have Oracle access to
the entries of a so now you have to do a
hamiltonian simulation with the square
root of the Hamilton so that's going to
add overheads
we just use a completely different
mapping right so this was like the
initial mapping but like this solution
is abandoned when I go to this the next
slide so this is a totally different way
of thinking about how I'm going to do
the mapping
if you're if you're wondering like
conceptually how we're getting around
like you have access to hamiltonian but
we wanted to Hamilton with summation
with square root how do you get around
the fact that you would in general need
to do the phase estimation it's because
the Hamilton is special it's the sum of
PSD terms and this is you can do in
general for Hamilton if you have a
hamiltonian that's the sum of
um
what's this technique called uh it's
called spectral Gap amplification
like Rolanda summer is one of the
authors of this paper and it's like if
you have Amazon that happens to be the
sum of projectors and you have this
explicit representation written down in
some oracles I think just written down
then you can do something much better
which is that you can
uh yeah essentially you can amplify the
spectral Gap so if you're trying to look
for the ground state energy you can do
quadratically better than you what you
would have thought you could do so it's
the same trick underlying this this
representation as well
any other questions so if I take some
hamiltonian
computing
and we
okay so let me get to that
um
is very very long but the output seems
to be only like the important to alter
the information regarding one
according to do that
how do I get this so yeah so for example
like in the way I formalize the problem
I just uh also this thing uh in the
special case I said all you do is figure
out this entry to edit it one or poly
error and that's just this fact that if
I allow you to sample from a
probabilities of distribution and ask
you what is the first entry of the
problem is like what's the problem is
that you sample one you can estimate
this probability to additive Epsilon
squared samples so this this Quantum
State like once I measure in the
standard basis you'll get
one this this entry with probability
that is the you know the kinetic energy
first of all and I just do this enough
time see how many times I get that and
that's going to give me an estimate of
this number and the decision problem was
just to decide if this number is bigger
or smaller than some some numbers
so at the moment
that's right so to get uh the second one
the quantity to one or poly and error I
like to sample it like this polynomial
squared number of times
um but the so you know to prove they
could be complete that's what I'm going
to do is like go through the circuit or
hamiltonian Direction starting from the
arbitrary Quantum circuit and showing
how you get the system of all these
things so this reduction is kind of
painful and
um maybe not super Illuminating instead
let me give you a different kind of
evidence for why this this problem is
hard which is that you can use it to
solve the glute transform there's a
famous problem that has an exponential
separation between Quantum and classical
because it's a
it's a natural algorithm for this
glutress question
um
so look let me hear a little bit about
this
so some of you have probably seen this
before but let me describe a second
anyway so the glucose problem is an
oracular problem so you have access to a
black box
that's encoding some graph that looks
like this and what's going on this graph
is you have some entrance vertex here
you have a balanced binary tree going
out from this with n layers and the same
thing here there's a balance by entry
going out and layers and in the middle
there's a random cycle that connects
these
and the Oracle you have and you know the
name of the entrance vertex so that's
what you're given and the Oracle you
have you can give it the name of a
Vertex and the Oracle will tell you it's
neighbor so for example the entrance
vertex it'll give you the labels of this
guy this guy if you give it this vertex
here it'll give you the labels of this
the forward here guys and and this guy
as well
and you only have this kind of oracular
information you're given the label of
the entrance vertex and your goal is to
Output the label of the exit vertex this
is the glute trees problem
and this little n is the the depth of
both of these three so the total number
of vertices here is something like uh
two to the n
two times two to the end you know
whatever it's exponential in little n
and what's also known is that any
classical algorithm whether it's
classical or deterministic or randomized
needs exponentially many queries
exponential and N to solve this problem
whereas there's a Quantum algorithm
which is based on a continuous time
Quantum that solves this problem in with
polynomial limited queries and I'm going
to show you how to reproduce the quantum
algorithm using balls and springs in
kind of the most obvious way which is
I'm going to put a ball at every vertex
and I'm going to put a spring at every
Edge so that's kind of what you would do
with a problem like this so okay there's
a red red dots or balls the blue lines
are Springs all the balls are mass one
all the Springs are spring constant one
it's a very simple system in that sense
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start by perturbing this entrance vertex
this is the only vertex is label I know
right
right so and the theorem that we show is
that there is some time T which is
polynomial at which the entrance vertex
will always also have inverse polynomial
velocity so what's happening is I give
the entrance vertex some velocity and
that this this like energy propagates to
the system and all the balls start
moving and whatever but there'll be some
time T at which this guy will have
inverse polynomial velocity this is not
obvious because there's exponentially
many balls here so this is something
that you have to prove but once you've
proved this then because of the thing we
show you can you can learn the name of
the exit vertex
so in this Bluetooth problem I forgot to
mention this but once you have a
candidate for the exit vertex you can
always check it because it's the only
other vertex in the graph that has two
um two neighbors so so even if like you
know you run this you run our previous
sampling algorithm it gives you a couple
of candidates that's okay you'll just
check them all with the oracle
so you can think of this as a different
way of rederiving the glue Trace
algorithm that has nothing to do with
Quantum walks or I mean of course
there's a Quantum algorithm involved but
at least if you want to explain this
algorithm to someone you could just say
oh it's just a bunch of balls connected
by Springs and I perturb the first guy
and after polymer time the last guy will
pick up some
kinetic energy
is there a physics situation why it
works
good questions
yeah is there a physics intuition
forward works so there is a physics
situation for why this works which is
actually the same intuition for y look
into some kind of work Works which is as
actually as like you can reduce this to
a smaller system of just 2N balls and
springs which is which corresponds to
the columns and this this perturbation
will transmit through the columns
equally like so all the balls in a given
column behave the same way
and so the radio system is just a bunch
of 2N balls connected by Springs of the
same spring constant except in the
middle as a different spring constant
and then you just Analyze This classical
system which is now of size n so that's
something you can even like you know
code up on a computer or whatever
because you have following your time you
analyze it and figure out at what time
will I actually propagate some velocity
the last
guy yeah it works and that's that's
different ways
no so all the Springs here appearing
here have uh spring constant one
observation is that when you do this
with the Springs it would also not know
it doesn't help you find the PATH right
right yeah this is a famous open problem
with blue trees right like finding a
path between the entrance and yeah our
solution doesn't help you do that
at all
um
no no so what happens is when you
analyze this in the Subspace of these
column registers you write down a
separate plug two in Dimensions
but that's just an effective system all
right
yeah because you don't want leak any
information in the algorithms right
which are the middle edges on which
other side so all the edges are the same
way and that persists in other
correlations with all the swings are the
same spring
and yes our algorithm solves this loot
Trace problem and uh as a Corollary
because the trace problem reduces to our
problem as a coronary any classic log of
the simulates our algorithm in fact will
also be what's our groceries which also
needs to be Omega and queries like the
classical lower body essentially goes
through for our problem as well as a
corollary office
[Music]
so basically given anything
um
uh
[Music]
right right
so what's this thing so oh so here
there's I mean the only thing I want to
present in the stock is that we can
solve the blue trees
no no it doesn't we have to do a
different analysis too I mean the
analysis at the end of the day is the
same thing but you know in the military
style what you do is instead of working
in the space of two to the end things
and work in the space of Two end things
we do the same thing but the what we
need to prove about it is slightly
different because the Dynamics is
different it's bald and strings it's not
a quantum
[Music]
but
but I suppose you can in principle can
you say more can you say more about why
why
uh Map works in this case
uh right so the analysis is yeah similar
because
of the military problem which is okay we
work in the space of your this reduces
to a system of just two end balls that
you know one for every column here and
the spring constraints will turn out to
be they'll all be the same except the
one in the middle will be like two times
bigger or something and now you have a
classical system of two N Things and you
have to analyze the question of if I
perturb the first guy if I give the
first guy velocity one like um will
there be a time which the last guy
against velocity one thing you can do is
you can just like solve this like on a
computer or something and you'll see
that it works but the way we prove it
analytically is we say uh you know yeah
would I done this classical system of
equations it's a matrix
um you know we
as I said before if you want to solve a
system of balls and springs you can just
write down this second order
differential equation this y double dot
is minus a y bar we take that Matrix we
analyze its spectrum and we show that
this this state this entrance state has
inverse polynomial overlap with all of
the eigenvectors
yeah yeah it's the same proof except
like we have to I mean it's the same
idea exactly but we're proving something
slightly different we're not showing
that the quantum what propagates we're
showing that this this this physical
disturbance of velocity goes through so
it's a slightly different equation but
the the proof technique is exactly the
same you analyze the same thing you say
show something about the eigenvectors be
sure it has good overlap you show that
yeah I'm just wondering why doesn't
generalized
um
yeah
and a single excitation should be
basically
a chain
of that system which moves around
because
I'm not exactly
it could be the same kind of work so it
could be like two extreme limits of the
same system right right
oscillator system
maybe to go from one to n whereas the
the quantum will be linear time like you
know Quantum Works propagate faster than
random walks right quadratically faster
you're saying like the classical system
if we solve it it'll be more analogous
I'm saying um I mean you could think of
both things to me I'm not sure if it's
exactly the same
which means basically that's a great I
think
and in the other case will be a
civilization which means it behaves like
a single like a number one because
there's only a single exhibition which
on the other if it's the same time you
want but it's a Quantum type of work
it could be two extremely limits of the
same situation
harmonica said is have a classic limit
and I think that one is really well
understood
I think there's probably something
general we can show but we didn't show
anything on the sword
um
what you would like a summer Zone that
says that you have a Quantum hamiltonian
you map it to classical system balls and
springs such that the time Evolution the
classical system recovers somehow the
task that was all but there's
yeah it's probably something that we
should show can you reduce from the
child Adele btp completeness of random
worlds yeah that's what
so this is the uh
sorry this is the convenience of which
Quantum loss exactly
is is
um to prove universality performance
basically you can start given given a
circuit you construct an exponential
sized rock yeah which basically
duplicates the the geometry of the
surfaces like throwing the circuit on a
two to the N uh size grid
um 2D
um and and then it's just a Quantum walk
on that with with the
hamiltonians having just Waits one on
each Edge
um
and then again it's exclusively like
what you were doing
it so if you could fix you should start
and starting with the challenge to
yourself then and and you have a general
statement that says that from such a
Quantum walk you can just place place
the balls on the notes and strings on
the edges then then yeah
yeah that sounds right
should be possible foreign
yeah
what happens in this uh in this um
a short description so you know if
you guarantee that this has a short
description and it's very recommended
thinking
so this problem is it's a purely or
regular problem it's not bqp complaint
because it doesn't have a succinct
description so it's only like you can
create as a quick completely problem
which has an exponential Gap in queer
complexity but it's not yeah it's
nothing it's not uh but yeah you're
saying if you just someone put some
constraint on this thing simple
um uh yeah I don't know maybe it depends
on in what way it's simple and if the
classical album question I'll learn that
um
the next slide is a summary
because I thought that would be this
would be more fun
production
it's not just that but
um yeah
I mean essentially you take our forward
reduction and work backwards through all
the stuff some of the steps don't go
backwards because
um
what will happen is you'll come you'll
need to hamiltonian that doesn't have
all positive entries and so on that we
need for spring constants but it's uh
maybe it's the same trick to send this
childhood that allows your Hamilton to
all have inches
extra
specific with the structure of them has
enough properties
yeah I guess that's something to think
about it we just yeah there's a couple
of things we need to fix one of them is
all the entries don't have the same sign
but you fix this by you know enlarging
the space and like working in us working
with like one of the registers being cat
minus secretes like not in the standard
basis it's also the same thing as I'm
just going to want people I think if
you're having the same Quantum is this
the one that says that both ever and
marvelous community no it's um
because of uh it basically like the
Electric electrical Network that works
the argument there
okay I should look at that
um
algorithm
and can you do something with a complete
I guess the algorithmic question is like
can you use this to solve interesting
problems that people actually care about
that alternatively about
either balls or Springs or whatever
you know the other way around is like
can you design Nick one of those using
the intuition from this ball that
Springs like we did for this blue trees
just
I mean so it might not just be like
special cases like this person that
might be just something fun to get on
let me show them we can recover all of
these algorithms but we couldn't like
proven you I come with a new point about
it by reasoning about classical systems
because there's a lot of people who are
more interested about classical systems
and so now they need somebody from you
know from that background comes and
develops an economies in this collection
that was very cool
um here's some open questions
thanks everyone
[Applause]
so is this is this limited to classical
with the same result basically also
apply if you have Quantum Mechanicals I
mean what happens
emissions because 10 of the math is very
similar when you know gaussian without
existence and classical systems right
I don't know the answer to that because
in the case is probably form a link
towards that in the box right because
the random walks is kind of just as a
case where you put
basically zero expectations and the
subject in terms of the same excitation
so that could maybe make a connection
but I don't know the answer that and
because I also didn't know what a
classical harmonics
this is all new to me so I don't know
what one of our money
right yeah yeah but I haven't thought
about the question
for this reason
you'll get um you need time to use
simulate these springs for time to you
know anytime
all right
no I mean tell me about the way we do it
um I'm wondering if they can also prove
that we can't fast forward
I don't know yeah
like at least
you know like all these algorithms that
are like you know we have electricity
Network you want to know what's you know
existence or something like there are
quantum models I mean I guess that's
probably the latest
but today
somehow picking your
framework basically could you say that
like these these on the wall algorithms
that are
using this electrical network formalism
but they are essentially
it's an instance
I think another interesting thing is
that um
like the military Evolution you could
simulate it by like just like you kind
of
before one of these calls and then the
rest of the ball starts bouncing and
their velocities and importance
sorry
but then you ask you know how would you
simulate the measurements is
the coral system because then what you
would want is to sort of like hold like
Hospital measurements to have all the
particles that fixed and only one of
them is
all the energy sort of is
like a physical mechanism
with probabilities proportional to the
volume the the velocities and the
coordinates sort of select one of the
balls
let's simulate the measurements
you know you could ask the first
question because
uh and then another remark is that there
is a couple years ago there's a paper
about
correspondence algorithm and this kind
of mechanical system where you have like
a wall yeah
basically there's like one loaded
standing another block is coming and
then it starts over now right and
there's a really like you can look at a
conservation of energy of these two
blocks
kind of like conservatively popular
and these two balances like between the
two blocks and between walls they
corresponded to reflections
um
I mean basically it seems like that
should be
like kind of more potential performance
basically
having some yeah
yeah that sounds very plausible in fact
Grover I think himself wrote a paper on
how you can think of drawers out of them
as something with a couple of pendulums
and a couple pendulums are the same
equations as walls and strings but what
you're talking about I think is a
different thing but yeah
exactly right so after this video like
somebody wrote a spectator
important
it might be yeah I think if you look at
it the right way especially if like
energy is involved like it might be just
doing this
yeah okay I agree there's like many
interesting
if you let the balls Collide and impart
momentum to another good thing to
simulate that
I don't know
no I don't know like I don't know any
other classical system for which
disorders like just
or something
special for this
I think it obvious to make
generalization is to take from domestic
effects
and many involves you know presumably
someone can start moving really
um
there's like all kinds of uh
differential equations that are very
fundamental that are more complicated
and
there is a lot of work on
solving differential equation on quantum
computers already
I don't know if it covers a specific
equation to care about but
um yeah for certainly a lot of work
this one in particular I've not been
considered before but yes it is
foreign
[Music]